hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to job simulator hi
jobbot how are you doing it's good to
see you anyway I was just trying to
record this and because this is all new
setup I accidentally broke everything
the recording failed I was trying to do
the auto mechanic and I only got half
way through and then everything exploded
literally there was goo everywhere and I
don't even know where it came from so
I'm gonna pick one of these eenie meenie
miney moe catch a tiger I'm gonna do the
gourmet chef boy because I actually chef
you sure do buddy look at me I actually
love cooking when the boys were living
here and they moved out back to Glendale
but uh when they were living here I love
to cook chicken and dumplings it was my
mom's recipe hello hi oh yes I'll take
it sorry got it okay I love bacon and
eggs even though I haven't had in a long
time cuz even though I said I like to
cook I actually was lying to myself
bacon whoo I feel good
it can be on the floor for at least a
little bit is this hot there we go yeah
I like it woo
it's so realistic its bubbling it I
wonder what would happen if I whoa I
didn't make me do that
I didn't mean to eat it right off the
grill Oh probably needs thank you oh
I was supposed to give that to a
customer and no I'm not gonna put the
wrist straps on because I like to live
dangerously okay I'm pretty sure I'm not
supposed to be doing this with just my
hands I mean all things considered I
just ate with my face on the grill and
probably have third-degree burns there
okay I guess that's good enough for
everybody
do I have to crack this oh what did
I do
let me just pick that up I no harm no
foul I love it when my eggs are on fire
they call it eggs benedict
Oh oh that would be much better than
just setting it on the dirty countertop
oh I'm sorry
ah my bacon what if my bacon go
jobbot give me the goddamn bacon back I
don't have any more bacon how am I
supposed here we go Oh unreality uh
breaking everything Oh God
let's just take that thank you Oh God
where'd it go
give it back please oh I am in a place I
should not be where's that goddamn bacon
oh jeez can I have this whoo okay we're
gonna be careful don't look at me like
that jobbot you know this perfectly
normal
I'm just a human that could face through
walls and objects you're just a machine
what are you gonna do in place of me huh
push your buttons there yeah okay boink
good enough congratulations robot I
don't know how you're gonna eat that but
hope you have fun with it this smoothie
is one of the most efficient forms of
human food efficient what blender are we
talking about here I do not see a
blender this is wasting fake energy I
really JIT Amelie when I went over there
I got I got a little bit of add to there
because I hate it when the doors are
left open on the refrigerator and I was
like yeah that's not supposed to be done
like that where's the goddamn blender am
I just supposed to shove it in my mouth
and chew with reckless abandon huh whoa
whoa cool where's the blender I can mean
I got the burnin ater oh that is so
convenient
oh that's space-saving I'm gonna stick
my hand in there
everyone loves a potato smoothie whoa oh
it's not done yet
yeah what happens if I do this oh oh oh
no tingling this some rather infected
corn get that in there good um oh
well it's half a peach anyway goddamn
it's half a peach why am i reaching
around it I can just go through it so
weird
Oh
all right good enough you got it buddy
boo it is still it's so weird because if
I'm not thinking about things I will try
to rest mine on real hand this fake
polygonal hand on the
countertop and that is bizarre and says
something about me or said something
about virtual reality in general hello
what's up next
I'm ready job oh hello customer that's
so real it's ok anyway so we need to get
a kettle here we need the pot and then
we need water which I'm assuming we're
gonna need the sink for that god this is
so cool I love this oh god why can't I
touch you why won't you let me close why
isn't this relationship progressing I
need water and I need I guess I can just
oh cattle mm I'll take that I again I
half expected that to have weight on it
when I was done all right well we're
gonna be doing this I might as well get
both so they can be a bit more efficient
about it well so long as I don't miss
the pot and just spray water all over
jobbot I don't think machines actually
take too kindly to that well I'm just
not doing good am I
wait oh that's not the right way to
do it god damn it I just want to do this
on the grill but that doesn't make any
sense why would you heat a kettle on the
book I mean I guess this is hot so it
work
all right fine whatever bloom yes indeed
quite what you want tea and crumpet King
I'm gonna throw it to you bastard
tee's best optimized for consumption by
being placed in a cup uh-huh okay you
got it okay all right you wanted t frump
it's also required okay you lost me here
crumpets require heat this is a bunch of
don't lie to me you okay where
we going crumpets crumpets crumpets
crumpets these crumpets I don't know
what British speak means
ah it's cooked yummy I don't need a
toaster screw your toast all right fine
the only other crumpet that I have here
boink how about another one boink boink
oh man this is good me I am bread
flashback I didn't mean to that was not
the intention oh just put it there okay
you want some more tea ah I missed
oh well what's next bunny boo come on
tell me I'm ready and women eating some
soup as you can see okay
salt the pot too just in case alright so
we need more water I had a better
vehicle for delivering water in there
but I mean okay perfect
I love corn soup I actually love corn on
the cob right there a little bit of
vintage grape juice not wine oh sorry
okay a little more in there everyone
loves cooking with wine Oh flower never
heard nobody some cooking soup sounds
pretty good to me I'm like a
four-year-old was trying to cook in the
kitchen won't get a bow and get a bone
you too boy stir it all up in there BAM
turn that heater up I don't know what
this is it's a cork I guess I
immediately knew what that was no no who
broke my goddamn dish did you do it you
British
I would what the what is this sixty
Seconds corn cookie and pretzel soup
naturally artificial you know if I
didn't know any better I'd assumed as
this is a computer simulation you're
just with me but whatever boink
Meridian's a ball like Mambo used to
make you don't have a mother this is a
sandwich sandwich what do you mean with
your Lisp okay
goddamnit I am bread what do you want
from me
is it a never-ending loaf of bread oh my
god it is oh my god it never ends I'm
somehow amazed and fascinated by this
one okay now what sandwich weiss why is
there something for sandwich I was my
kitchen at a setting for goddamn Seth
that was bread always hear a that
lab that on there I like it raw I like
it as rare as can be
Oh chicken legs good that is I hope it's
a meatball I mean even what I think it
might be it might still be a meatball
but I'm not a hundred percent I want to
know little mushroom I hate mushroom but
I'm not eating this so who gives a
let's get more layers on there's get
some milk I don't like sour milk
sandwich Ashley boy young yay okay
sandwich thanks Shabbat it is pretty
sandwich I got this why am i trying to
balance this it's all fake it's all in
my mind it's not real
you forgot your milk eat a damn
eat milk and drink milk whatever I don't
know I used to work in a restaurant
looks delicious
I don't know what I'm supposed to do
with this I mean I know it's fake my
mind is telling me that this is
absolutely not juicy but ignorance is
bliss okay here we go
how do I is this all I'm supposed to do
because frankly
okay I mean that's a double strike right
there what happens if I put olive oil in
a cup would you like that in this
deforestation cup anybody want some
probably delicious I mean you're French
you wouldn't know the difference huh
hubba sorry I really wanted to bite it
off of there damn it it's not real life
there you go buddy
French lovely person I'm ready are you
ready no make sure our service is
exceptional
piss on the bleep - are you well I want
it I want to eat there's fine whatever I
don't care
it was his sake he brought it in if it's
bad it's his fault
hello welcome to the restaurant how many
kids know you absolutely cannot only
define there's a combination of bread
tomato and cheese oh uh okay you know
what I'm not gonna argue with you
because frankly I don't even know how to
make pizza even though it's really
simple and most diamonds is frozen and
delivered pizza that I eat I'll give it
a go and I'm really gonna try this time
enough sarcasm out of me you're not
gonna get a single joke it's serious
business up in here okay never mind then
well good thing I got all this bread on
the floor no one seemed to mind yeah I
love pizza
oh this is good okay so I just slap that
in there throw that in there nuke it at
a thousand megawatts good enough
probably good looks like enough
discipline
I have some questions about the logic
behind this
I mean I'm open-minded don't get me
wrong and I would be more than hoops I
would be more than happy to have that
come out if I put bread tomatoes and
cheese in a microwave but frankly uh
whatever they're happy with a happy
ending kids it's gonna be fine I can't
read this no tomatoes
could you make a special slice what do
you want instead of sauce on your pizza
Timmy okay
applesauce it is I'm not one to question
the customer especially when the robot
overlords that consumed my entire
existence and killed off every other
human so that I have to live my
existence like this so here we go with
your stupid apple pizzas okay then you
know I love you and explode oh I
couldn't do that I mean I was gonna
punch it out of my chest after the
moment arrived but apparently not okay
sandwich I mean I don't even understand
how are you people eating these things I
mean I get it's a simulation just from
my entertain that's gonna be awkward
okay whatever it's a ring sandwich
Oh
I don't understand anything is what the
how did that get on there well
whatever let's crank the tunes and get
the romance started oh I brought you to
put this on hang on
we're a new totally disco hey I'm
running the show on the Romanticism so
you all shut up interesting what do you
mean my sweet I emotion you are you
enter a legally binding partnership with
me yeah why'd you run away oh did she
follow with you he I don't know your
robots you even have genders fine next
here we go I like weird cake but you do
get a free birthday cake
right why I'm not even making any money
off of this I'm doing this for
quote-unquote fun okay when you said
that word I was a little curious about
what you were talking about oh I get it
flower hahaha
carrot cake i likey K I am drooling
everywhere but that's because I'm losing
my mind and it's oozing out the bun all
right here comes a great cake little
Timmy Bailey whatever your name
was oh look at that little Tim Tim here
you go Bing bong goo Ding Dongs have a
good day Oh party left a huge pile of
dirty dishes we're gonna need your help
to get through these they're the poor
nasty so make sure you use a good score
too so I'm the boss I'm the boss someone
didn't tell me that I was the boss here
and if I'm the boss why am i doing
dishes is this fun yeah god this is so
realistic I'm almost as bores I could be
headed out of a
let another Nino
I don't know
but if I just oh I am skilled ha ha I'm
gonna assume that that went exactly as I
imagined it did not because the program
existed my own stupidity because I don't
need I don't need that was supposed to
be much smoother but take it it's been
ok I only have two hands why'd you hand
me the box where am I supposed to do can
I blend it up you get that box out of my
face let's see hey hi hey cutie are you
doing
just tell you these results okay good
enough you want some slop we got plenty
of high quality slop here fresh out of
the blender we can get back to business
oh boy I can't wait yeah hey I was like
10 for 10 it's a bomb with you okay but
this is a simulation you know that right
it's not real who the hell are you okay
okay we got some fresh bug juice here
don't mind my not being able to
pronounce words correctly fresh bug
juice okay is this for ramen I love
ramen but I don't know what I'm gonna do
there you go buddy
I mean fats let's get you off took a
bite is this gonna kill me oh thank you
why why am I doing this I just did that
why do I get to do it again I don't even
more I already feel like my intentions
are melting away all right here we go
ahh
flavor food with flavor human all of the
flavor okay whatever you say
I found this rare turbo don't stand Nova
pepper can you prepare for me eat it
then oh you don't understand cuz you're
a robot it's so hot it's ransoming all
over the place also screams how about
some microwave Oh
boink this'll be the one for you there
you go have fun
don't die if you even can die which I
don't think you can hey chef
we got three BOTS out here to ordered
the special not sure what that means but
that's what they want we're in the
solution means placing your trust in the
ship I'm going to be exactly uncreated
because I'm gonna put sriracha on a
potato and then hope for the best
boink looks interesting okay how about
how about a corn cob sandwich that's
always everybody's favorite boink and a
little garnish a little a little look
it's blocked by the corn the corn is too
thick little garnish and there we go
you got it officer anything for the
officer of the law
how about an irradiated cactus all right
you're welcome there buddy hope you're
having a good day well that didn't do
nothin Oh everything's on fire why is
everything on fire oh I'm trying to
alright how do I
I'm trying it yeah I did my best
what am i oh god what am I doing wrong
what do I do
oh do I oh that makes sense
you're welcome buddy I don't know what
you said but you're welcome I'll be on
Tammy is the peak of human achievement
oh yay
good for me what am I saying dude oh you
ready human no bring in the talent I
thought I was the talent wait a minute
hi nice to meet you human home shift
boat remson
Oh No the meatball scene the big boss
scene well what are we doing family I'm
very lonely oh oh okay I didn't know
that oh I'm just like them listen to you
ramble because I know I'm bad you don't
need to tell me I'm bad I'm totally
aware of the capacity my suckage how
about this these look good to question
mark nice and burns what about this one
there we go point bookies and graphing
calculators good okay that was good
Gabrielle so you I know I could be
a little tired on camera but it's all
just part of the show you know all right
seem to that's the freeform cooking part
great okay
shows what you can do the only thing I
actually learned how to cook on this
show was bacon and eggs and even that
was kind of questionable because I'm not
pretty sure that I did it well I'm I'm
serving it I'm serving it big in the egg
Bama what everybody wants it's good
stuffs did I do good respect for you
after this no it didn't seem like you
respected me at all in fact it seemed
like you hated me you do whatever you
want uh I'd rather not stay here you
know I have a normal life that I want to
go out and do things in the real world
and that would be lovely to get to so
I'm gonna do that so I'm here baby
whoo so anyway this said oh really on it
by the way some of you caught that much
yes really
okay so that's the end of the chef's job
simulator I actually used to work in a
restaurant a long time ago I probably
should have talked about that while I
was doing it but they were kept talking
in my ear so thank you everybody so much
for watching I'm gonna do the other ones
I'll probably do auto mechanic glass cuz
it's failed for me last time and
hopefully this didn't fail so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
so I should